is that the Robin Hood yeah yeah look at
now you like it the beard yeah I feel
like it as a guy it's pretty easy I roll
out of bed ya know the shower brush my
teeth and leave it's pretty good amazing
so I mean this is the second installment
with Kim joining the cast I mean yeah I
mean what was I liked having someone of
that iconic nature beautiful yeah I
should have still can't believe a man
appeared with Kim you know growing up by
80s Kim was always a name that I would
use as an example in the playground of
like what like a really pretty woman is
you know so um actually no I'd be in a
movie with his incredible um and she was
great man everyone loved her and she
just you know came in and there's no
fussing she's actually very child it'll
girl from Georgia you know and I'm still
very much feels like that and she looks
incredible still you know and yes mad
okay you know RDD to say you know groups
like how many babies are a group is
responsible for the conception of these
I'm wanting for you how many times that
people came and told you this is the 50
shades babe um the I hate not that many
times buff is not a couple times I did
have a nice situation in an elevator
once where a woman told me that um she
recognized me from from the medium and
said that she and her husband had had
trouble conceiving and then not long up
very very late a girl pregnant so it'll
get a nice touching story that came from
is a good are you getting I mean I
imagine you know sex scenes in movies
are never comfortable and nobody might
with dis many people who might be
uncomfortable are you getting more
comfortable with that kind of thing or
does it ever get comfortable I probably
don't want to make it too much of a
hobbit has done the mouth sections might
probably find enough of them for a whole
tray area I'm sure they'll come up again
at some stage and so close but you do
it's never totally comfortable but you
definitely the more you do it the more
comfortable it becomes and then you
should it's a scary how a comfortable it
is by by the end when
think back to how uncomfortably or the
first time you did it but Dakota and I
being very shy and understanding each
other that that helps with always more
comfortable you are her I think it's
more comfortable for her based on the
fact that she's usually the one and more
compromise you know I'm usually the one
with sort of in control of everything
and calling Michelle so probably more
comfortable for her definitely